[Music]
who was one of the first to um
champion inclusivity on the runway and
in his collections
um and was a man of many talents
okay what can you tell us about the
upcoming season of lincoln empire
wow there is so it's loaded it's fully
loaded you definitely have to have
strapped in seat belts all over um but
there's a lot of fashion
because i do take kevin to paris for
couture week
and kevin's never been you know outside
of
i don't know his apartment
but i love him he's like my little
brother um so we really explore all of
what paris has to offer especially
during couture week what was the
highlight for you taking kevin there
taking cameras there
is there a specific moment that stands
out yes that's such a great question
i've been i've been um attending fashion
weeks for i don't know 15 or so years so
sometimes you kind of take it for
granted but to see it fresh through
kevin's eyes and to experience it
completely from scratch from through his
eyes and
in his vision and it's just it's so much
fun it's like doing it for the first
time again absolutely i became like a
fashion virgin again
has it surprised you at all how much
people have fallen in love with this
show
[Music]
yeah i mean we're very humbled by it i'm
very humbled by it but it's about damn
time to quit the great lizzo right um
it's asian americans are severely
underrepresented um in popular media and
we're really grateful for the
opportunity
and when it comes to asian
representation and fashion what are your
thoughts i mean obviously we're not
there yet so what do you think we need
to be doing here
i think
progress is everything and each designer
in each collection encourages the next
so as long as we're all doing our parts
and supporting you said inclusivity
right and
yes
i just came from the jason wu show and
it was
breathtaking he is so talented and so
humble jason wu woo
and um i am so proud to you know to have
him represent
us
in the fashion world in such a big
miraculous and amazing significant way